on annonce décroche il y avait des
mesures très ambitieuse alors qu'en
réalité il s'agit d'une baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre net
ce qui veut dire qu'en fait on va
déduire des émissions des transports etc
on va on va faire une déduction de ce
qui est capté par les puits de carbone
naturels donc en réalité c'est moins
ambitieux qu'avant voire pareil donc en
fait on va dire que c'est de la
communication en effet je pense qu'il ya
en effet d'autres priorités on parle pas
beaucoup des pesticides donc pas
beaucoup finalement de la façon dont on
va faire cette transition énergétique
que feu au niveau de l'europe au niveau
de chaque pays des propositions
d'objectifs qui me semble relever un peu
de la propagande électorale alors que ce
problème est très compliqué très
difficile à résoudre
et donc dans le green deal en question
moi je ne vois pas les choses
essentielles
alors les choses essentielles allons
droit au but si vous comparez la france
et l'allemagne
eh bien la france et pas mal dé carbonée
alors que en allemagne le kilowattheure
on émet deux fois plus de carbone qu en
france et puis on va avoir besoin de
plus d'électricité
ce qu'il faut décarbonés le chauffage
des bâtiments et le transport mais ça
s'est beaucoup beaucoup d'énergie et
donc bon bah écoutez nous on ferme les
centrales nucléaires parce que je sais
pas si mal vu
bon je crois que c'est l'erreur
[Musique]
si on arrivait à réduire de 40 % en 2030
c'est presque demain ça est de 100 % en
2050 les émissions de carbone sur des
carbonnais aussi vite que ça ce serait
un assaut de sauvetage il faudrait que
les autres pays en fassent autant bon
pour le climat bon mais le problème
c'est qu'il suffit pas d'afficher un
objectif c'est ce que j'ai dû essayer de
dire des à tout à l'heure il se fait pas
ni de dire ah ben on n'a pas fait assez
pour le climat on agit sur 40 pensa
alors on va dire 50% ces mêmes 55
d'ailleurs je crois mais non soyons un
peu sérieux et pragmatique comment fait
on il ya les barrages hydroélectriques
ça s'est très très bien
c'est propre ça ce pilote
c'est très très bien on a la chance d'en
avoir en france 10 ou 15% je crois notre
site et qui vient et ça c'est très très
utile pourquoi parce que les deux autres
là le photovoltaïque ça s'arrête là nuit
il n'y a pas de soleil la nuit se
s'arrête presque aussi quand et puis les
éoliennes bakaja pas devant ce rapport
mais en fait c'est déjà trop tard
donc il faut limiter les dégâts il faut
aller vite en effet mais pas faire
n'importe quoi donc je ne dis pas non
plus de tout faire dans la précipitation
c'est pas ça simplement que les dates
qui sont annoncés encore une fois c'est
le assez lointains et à ses proches pour
que ça fasse rêver en montant ne soit
pas trop accessible déco plus oublier à
ce moment là je préférais bien en 2050
on ne sera pas là à mon avis donc pour
moi c'est ce jus des chiffres annoncés
un petit peu au hasard
simplement je pense que oui par
l'écologie c'est pas quelqu'un en
comptabilité et en même temps il ya
quand même un besoin d'un financement et
d'une préparation est en effet il faut
s'appuyer sur les connaissances de
physiciens scientifique je ne suis
absolument pas contre bien au contraire
maintenant on voit qu'il ya des
recherches qui sont réalisés pour
justement arrivé à stocker cette énergie
quand il n'y a plus de vent peut-être
que cette énergie on peut les stocker ou
la transformer
je sais qu'il ya des recherches dans ces
domaines là maintenant la géothermie
dans l'hydraulique
voilà mais c'est une volonté politique
je pense que tout est possible et tout
est finançable mois après pas n'importe
comment comme mais il y à des recherches
qui ont été effectuées je pense
d'ailleurs à pierre larrouturou qui
avait fait une grève de la faim pour
demander une taxe sur la spéculation qui
rapporterait 50 7 milliards d'euros par
an pour simplement peut-être 0 01 % taxe
sur ces spéculations et qui financerait
en partie en grande partie ce pacte vert
donc le voyez bien que les solutions il
y en a donc on préfère annoncer les
chiffres lointain que de donner des
solutions concrètes et quantifiables et
c'est toutes ces recherches ont été
faites on n'a plus d'enfant il ya
urgence
donc faut y aller pas à pas mais il faut
y aller il ya une autre solution qu'on
envisage c'est l'hydrogène
effectivement on pourrait penser qu'avec
des panneaux solaires
on va faire de l' électrolyse de
l'électrolysé de l'eau et que ça va
produire de l'hydrogène et que cet
hydrogène
on va la stocker quelque part avant de
s'en servir
alors c'est bien bon d'accord mais
d'abord ça coûte très cher pour
l'instant et puis d'autre part on la
stoppe comment donc il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de recherches c'est très
important sur l'hydrogène et sur les
batteries mais c'est ça qu'il faut faire
oui c'est ça on a des progrès à faire là
c'est là qu'il peut mettre des milliards
dans la recherche